اعتمدت الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده بل
الاغلبيه قرار ان يطالب يطلب رايا قانونيا
من محكمه العدل الدوليه بشان الاثار
القانونيه للاحتلال الاسرائيلي للاراضي
الفلسطينيه ورحبت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
بالقرار وقالت انه قد ان الاول لمحاسبه
اسرائيل بينما اعربت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
عن غضبها ووصفت القرار الدوليه بانه وصمت
عار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مصارعه
ما الذي يمكن ان يبنى قانونيها وسياسيا
على قرار الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
وايا مال لتلك الانتهاكات في ظل حكومه
نتنياهو الاكثر ايميليه في تاريخ اسرائيل
ثم نبحث في كيف ستتعامل حكومه مع هذه
الخطوه واي موقف للمجتمع الدولي خصوصا
واشنطن اذا اتراكم بملفات الانتهاكات
الاسرائيليه بين يدي محكمه العدل الدوليه
ثم ماذا بوسع الاطراف الفلسطينيه فعله
الاستثمار هذه الخطوه لما يقدمه حقوق
الفلسطينيين ومطالبهم بالنظر ترحيب
بالسلطه وحركه حماس
[موسيقى]
قرار ازعج اسرائيل ودفع رئيس وزراءها
بنيامين نتنياهو للتعليق عليه بانتقادات
شديده يحيل انتهاكات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الى انظار محكمه العدل الدوليه وهو الهدف
الذي طال ما سعى الفلسطينيون لتحقيقه
لتبقى فاعليته
رهينه متى ترد به محكمه العدل الدوليه من
تكييف لتلك الانتهاكات وتحديد لمدى
اختصاصها بها فضلا عن التابعات القانونيه
التي ستجر عن تبنيها لملف تلك الانتهاكات
اين يكون الحال فان اليد الفلسطينيه تبدو
مصره على طرق كل الابواب في مواجهه
ممارسات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فاا عن العام
الماضي قال نادي الاسير الفلسطيني ان
القوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اا ذكرى طبعا
لا حاصرا اعتقلت 7000 في فلسطينيه نادي
الاسير ذكر في بيان ان المعتقلين بينهم
882 طفلا
و172 امراه واوضح ان مدينه القدس المحتله
شهدت اعلى نسبه اعتقال خلال العام المنصرم
بنحو ثلاثه الاف معتقل وان اكثر من 2400
امر اعتقال اداري صدر بحق اسرى فلسطينيين
دون تقديم لوائح التهام واتهم البيان
سلطات الاحتلال بممارسه القتل البطيء من
خلال الاهمال الطبي بحق الاسره
حركه حماس قالت تعليقا على الخطوه الامميه
ان تصويت الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
لصالح القرار ينضم الى سلسله طويله من
القرارات الدوليه التي لم تتحول الى خطوه
ضاغطه على الاحتلال
فيها الى تطبيق عملي على الارض ما دامت ان
الولايات المتحده التعامل بمنطقه الشريف
الفلسطيني وتوفر غطاء كامل الاحتلال في
هذه المؤسسات ستبقى كل هذه القرارات حمرا
على ورق استمرار السعي الدبلوماسيه رسميه
للسلطه باستصدار هذه القرارات والعمل بهذه
الطريقه هو تعبير عن عكسها في مواجهه
حقيقيه مع الاحتلال وضعف واضح فيها
هيكليات عملها
من جانبه الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس قال
ان الشعب الفلسطيني سيهزم كل المحاولات
البائسه لحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو الجديده
وفق تعبيره وسيبقى الفلسطينيون متمسكين
بحقوقهم التاريخيه والقانونيه
ادعو الجميع لحوار وطنيا
فلسطينيا سياسيا شامل في القريب العاجل
للعمل والتصدي معا
وتحمل المسؤوليه معا
والشير نحو تحقيق اهدافنا معا
وفي رده على القرار قال رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ان قرار الامم
المتحده لن يكون ملزما للحكومه
الاسرائيليه ونشرت هيئه البث الاسرائيلي
عبر تويتر مقطع فيديو لرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي وهو يرد على قرار الامم
المتحده قائلا ان هذا القرار يشبه مئات
القرارات التي اتخذت في الجمعيه العامه ضد
اسرائيل والتي وصفها بالمشوهه ووصف
ريترياه القراره بالحقير وقال ان الشعب
اليهودي ليس محتلا لارضه ولا محتل لعاصمته
الابديه القدس حسب تعبيره واشار الى انه
اجرى محادثات في الايام الاخيره مع عدد من
زعماء العالم الذين غيروا تصويتهم حسب
تعبيره
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من غزه
راجيه صوراني مدير المركز الفلسطيني لحقوق
الانسان ومن نيويورك الدكتور عبد الحميد
صيام الخبير في شؤون الامم المتحده ومن
واشنطن ادوار جوزيف المدير التنفيذي لمعهد
الشؤون الدوليه بمركز الدراسات عبر
الاطلسي وابدا بضيف نيويورك الدكتور
من قبل الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده باخذ
هذا الراي القانون المحكمه العدل الدوليه
وهنا انقل من قاله نتانيا
من القرارات من قبل الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده وبالتالي ماذا عن هذه الخطوه
وثقالها ومراميها
شكرا اخي عبد القادر تحيه لك والضيوفك كل
عام وانتم بخير
اعتقد ان هذا القرار مختلف قليلا عن
القرارات السابقه
وشبهه بقرار
1975 حول موضوع الصهيونيه شكل من اشكال
العنصريه والتمييز العنصري والذي فعلا
اثار القيادات الاسرائيليه انا ذاك ولم
ينام الليل حتى استطعوا ان يلهوه عام 1991
لانه يحاكم الفكر يحاكم العقيده وليس فقط
الممارسات هذا القرار الذي سيذهب الى
محكمه العدل الدوليه ستصدر فيه فتوى حول
شرعيه الاحتلال حول قانونيه الاحتلال لذلك
هم يخافون اذا صدر راي قانوني من اعلى
سلطه دوليه في القانون الدولي تقول ان هذا
الاحتلال غير قانوني ويجب ان ينتهي وهو
يعطل حق الشعب الفلسطيني في تقرير مصيره
فهذا هو
لكل الممارسات الاسرائيليه جمله وتفصيلا
والجزء الثاني من الفتوى المطلوبه ان يقدم
مجموعه طلبات ليس فقط
للامم المتحده كي تتعامل مع هذا الاحتلال
غير القانوني ولكن ايضا مع كافه الدول اي
انها ستطلب من هذه الدول ان تعمل معا
لانهاء هذا الاحتلال الذي تحول بشكل دائم
الى اقرب الى الاستعمار وليس فقط الاحتلال
مهم ان يقرا القرار ولذلك وضعت اسرائيل
الضغوطا شديده على جميع الدول حتى تغيرتها
واعطيك مثال في التصويت الاولي على اهم
مشروع هذا القرار في اللجنه الرابعه
اللجنه تصفيه الاستعمار بتاريخ 11 نوفمبر
همم
2022 صوت الى صالحه 98 دوله وصوت ضده 17
لكن في التصويت يوم الجمعه مساء الجمعه
صوت 87 دوله اي في تسع دول تراجعات وسوط
همم ضده 26 دوله يعني من 17 الى 26 ومن 98
الى 87 تراجع وزاد عدد الدول الممتعه عن
التصميم صوتا واحدا من 52 الى 53
ساعود لك دكتور عبد الحميد باشارتك
للضغوط والتمكن هذه المره من تمرير هذه
خطوه من قبل الجمعيه العامل المتحده من
واشنطن همم ادوارد جوزيف ال- ال- القرار
جاء بعد خمس سنوات من تقديم الجانب
الفلسطيني لهذه لهذا لهذا الملف في
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده باعتقادك
لماذا تم الان بعد تقريبا كل هذه السنوات
خمس سنوات من الضغوط من قبل اسرائيل من
جهه وكذلك من قبل الاداره الامريكيه بان
لا يمرر هذا القرار
القرار وبكل بساطه لانه كانت هناك اصوات
كافيه للتمريره في الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده
لكن كما قال المتحدث السابق هذه المره
هناك اقل من الاغلبيه صوتات وهي التي مررت
هذا القرار وهذا له اهميته لان المحكمه
محكمه العدل الدوليه في لها سوف
تلاحظ هذه الامور في هاي وترى في هذا طبعا
هم لديهم ميل بعد
انفسهم في قرارات
سياسيه وتحويل المحكمه الى نزاعات من هذا
النوع ذات الطبيعه السياسيه البح وليس
القانونيه وهذا يثير يسير نقطتين من نقاط
الخطر على الفلسطينيين وليس على
الاسرائيلين اولهما يمكن ان يخسروا القضيه
لان السؤال المطروح والاشكاليه المطروحه
امام المحكمه هو هل ان الاحتلال اصبح امر
واقع ضما من جانب اسرائيل بامكان المحكمه
تقول لا الامر لا يرقى الى مستوى الضم
والفلسطيني يمكن ان يخسروا القضيه
العنصر الخطر الثاني هو بامكانهم ان
يفوزوا عندما تقول المحكمه ان هذا ظما
واذا قات المحكمه ذلك لن لن يكون امامنا
اياه اي حائض حوله دون ظلمه للضفه الغربيه
غزه
فقالت بوضوح كما اننا تممنا هذه الارض اذا
سنضمها فعلا
اعود الى سؤالي انا اعلم بان هذا القرار
تمريره بالاغلبيه هذا امر بديهي ولكن سؤال
كيف نجح الان بعد كل هذه السنوات من عدم
التمكن من تمريره هل معنى ذلك ان الضغوط
اصبحت اقل على الدول غيرت قرارها وصلحت
وصوتت لصالح هذا المشروع هذا هو هدف سؤالي
وائل
القضيه
الاستمرار
[موسيقى]
والهمه والسعي والاصرار
والقضيه ان هذه القضيه
لم يطرح الا الان وتم التصويت
السابق الذي وضع الامور في السياقه في
سياق القرار المسير الجزر وهو قرار اعتبار
الصهيونيه
وذلك القرار لم يفتت الفلسطينيين لكنه
اظرهم واضر بسرعه الامم المتحده وما زال
يضر المتحده حتى اليوم لان الامم المتحده
لم ينظر اليك بسيط نزيه في المشكله بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين لهذا السبب
اعتقده ان محكمه العدل
يمكن ان تتخذوا قرارا في وقت مجلس الامن
هم من قسم المهمه
لضيفي من واشنطن اثار مساله مهمه ان ما
جرى اليوم
ليس بالضروره هو نقطه ايجابيه في صالح
السلطه الفلسطينيه وانما هما نقطتان
تتحديان السلطه الفلسطينيه في حاله حتى
قبول محكمه العدل الدوليه كيف تعلق
اولا اريد ان اؤكد ان هذه الخطوه هي خطوه
حكيمه ذكيه وهي استراتيجيه بالمعنى
القانوني
هي خطوه في منتهى الاهميه وتم الاعداد لها
من قبل فريق من الخبراء متميز
ومتمكن
وهذا هذه هي المره الثانيه التي تتوجه بها
فلسطين من اجل طلب راي استشاري من محكمه
العدل الدوليه وهي المحكمه الاكثر اهميه
على وجه هذه الارض
تم المره الاولى في العام 2004 وهذه هي
المره الثانيه وهذه المره همم تاتي لطرح
سؤال واضح محدد وبسيط في شكله ولكن مهم
جدا في مضمونه القانوني هو يسال ما اذا
كان هذا الاحتلال قانوني ام غير وان ربما
يستغرب البعض لاحتلال هو امر قانوني
وبالامكان اللجوء له من الدول في حالات
محدده لكن نحن تحدث عن الاحتلال الاكثر
غرابه والاكثر طولا والاكثر عسكره والاكثر
دمويه والذي همم
العام همم
الماضي والعام قبل الماضي
والصيف ليس فقط بانه همم دموي وهمم قمعي
واحلالي وكولونيالي ولكنه هو نسخه جديده
من الابارتيد غير مضبوقه اذا السؤال هل
هذا الاحتلال قانوني ام غير قانوني هذا ما
ستجيب عليه لا يوجد مبرر لدى همم
اي احتلال وبالذات هذا الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي همم
لاستمرار هذا الاحتلال الذي يمنع ممارسه
الشاعر الفلسطيني حقه في تقرير بصير وكل
ما تطرح اسرائيل من اسباب او ضرائع
لاستمرار هذا الاحتلال هو غير مقبول هو
غير مقبول
بالمستوى القانوني وندى ذو الفقهاء
القانون الدولي والقانون الدولي الانساني
همم هذا الامر لم يعد مجديا لذلك التوجه
همم هذا لم يكن حديثا ولم يكن وليد الساعه
طيب همم جون دوقعد وهو احد اهم
المقررين الخاصين في تاريخ القضيه
الفلسطينيه ومايكل لينك بروف شون مايكل
لينك عندما كانوا مقررين خاصين للاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله طرحه هذا الامر وبقوه
ولكن كان هناك حاجه للدراسه والتعميق هذا
سبب الغضب الشديد من قبل امريكا واسرائيل
على هذا القرار هذا هو السبب ان همم كثير
من دول اوروبا الغربيه مع الاسف التي تملك
معايير مزدوجه وخفت وصوت الضد والبعض
الاخر امتنع نحن امام حالت اختبار انساني
اخلاقي قانوني اي عالم نحضريه في هذا
الصراع تحديدا
اسال الله الدكتور عبد الحميد الصيام عن
محاوله فهم الجانب القانوني ولا بعد
القانونيه في انتظار ما ستقوله محكمه
العدل الدوليه استمعت الى ضيف قبل قليل
منه واشنطن يقول ان قرار المحكمه حتى وان
صدرها هذا الرئيس الاستشاري قد يضع الجهه
الفلسطينيه هي في من يضعها في الماء
الازرق
ماذا عن هذا البعد وما قاله ضيفي من
واشنطن برايك
يعني هذه تمنيات فقط
الخيال وليس الواقع اولا
تعني انقاذ
اقتراح تحويل قضيه الاحتلال الى محكمه
العدل الدوليه لم ياتي فقط من السلطه
الفلسطينيه انا اريد ان اوضح انه جاء من
لجنه الامم المتحده المستقله المعنيه
بانتهاكات حقوق الانسان في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله بما فيها القدس
واسرائيل الذي انشاؤه مجلس حقوق الانسان
في 27 ايار مايو 2021 بعد معركه سيف القدس
هذا هو الفريق الذي طلب من الجمعيه العامه
ان تحيل مساله الاحتلال الى محكمه العدل
الدوليه قدم تقريرا بتاريخ 22 اكتوبر قدمه
الرابعه له المعنيه بتصفيه الاستعمار مكون
من 28 صفحه فيه اا توصياح واضحه بتحويل
الاحتلال الى محكمه العدل الدولي هاي نقطه
النقطه الثانيه محكمه العدل الدوليه تنظر
في الجوانب الكترونيه ليس لها في قضيه
السياسه عندما تاتيها قضيه تنظر اليها من
الناحيه القانونيه هل هذا قانوني او لا
مثلا القذافي كان يقول ان اقليم اوزو هو
تابع لليبيا همم تشاد قالت لا هو تابع لنا
ذهب القضيه الى محكمه العدل الدوليه ثم
اصدرت فتواها بان اقليم اوزو هو يتبع
للشاهد وليس ليبيا وكذلك جزر حنيش في
اليمن هل هي اللي اريتريا ام لليمن محكمه
العدل الدوليه قالت لليمن تفقد طرفان
وعادت لليمن هذه هي قضايا سياسيه وصراعات
لكن هي المحكمه تنظر من الجانب القانوني
فقط هذا الاحتلال كما قال اخي راجي يجوز
للدول المتحاربه تحتل ارضا في فتره
المواجهات لفتره معينه الى ان تنتهي الحرب
القانوني والتداعيته السياسيه ووقت
البرنامج ضيق جدا لذلك اعتذر منك واذهب
الى ضيفي في واشنطن رصيد ادوارد جوزيف
لفهم رد الفعل الاسرائيلي حتى الان رئيسا
وزراء نتنياهو يصف هذه خطوه بانه امر
يعني حتى المصطلح فيه الكثير من التعدي
السياسي على منظمه بحجم الامم المتحده
اليس هذا دليل ان هذه الحكومه الموصوف
بانها الاكثر تتطرفا في حاله انزعاج شديد
من هذه الخطوه
همم الله همم
الناس ناس عواصف اسرائيل
هناك هناك الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
ان ان هذه هذا القرار نفسه
الهدف من سؤالي سيد ادوارد الهدف من سؤالي
بالاشاره الى مقاله ان مد انزعاج الحكومه
الاسرائيليه من هذا من هذه الخطوه لم يبقى
معي الا 30 ثانيه ضيف السيد راجي الصوراري
عن كيف يستطيع الجانب الفلسطيني في اقل من
20 ثانيه ان يستفيد من هذه الخطوه
ويستثمرها
من خلال توجه الى هذه المحكمه
واظهار حاله التفوق الانساني والاخلاقي
والقانوني على عدو يمارس جرائم حرب
والجرائم ضد الانسانيه همم الفريق
القانوني بتقديري الفلسطيني سيكون اكثر من
رائع شكرا
في هذا المجال سنضع كل مواردنا
وامكانياتنا في خدمه هذا الامر ونحن امام
العربيه
ان ان ان ان ان يؤكد واقول ان لا يوجد شعب
تحرر بقرار من المحكمه لدى همم
شكرا جزيلا
كتاب الحلقه الى اللقاء باذن الله
[موسيقى]